en el año 2015 en un supermercado de
buenos aires argentina específicamente
en el pasillo del papel higiénico me
topé con una mujer de aproximadamente 25
ó 30 años ella estaba paralizada
observando fijamente los anaqueles y no
se decidía por ninguna opción y les
puedo asegurar que había muchísimas
tenía como la mirada perdida ustedes
saben que los seres humanos somos muy
curiosos y por supuesto llegué a
preguntarme pero qué tanto eleva el
papel higiénico observándolo por unos
minutos me di cuenta como de una manera
muy sutil estaban saliendo lágrimas de
sus ojos ni lo dudé por supuesto y me
acerqué para preguntarle estás bien
ella volteo y ya había perdido el
control absoluto de sus lágrimas y solo
pudo pronunciar dos palabras me dejó
recuerdo en ese momento abrazarla muy
muy fuerte y decirle tranquila todas
estamos librando alguna batalla
desde ese momento se generó una conexión
inexplicable desde ese momento entendí
que se puede conectar de corazón a
corazón recuerdo sentir un vínculo muy
muy fuerte
con aquella mujer desconocida en el
pasillo del supermercado este día llegué
a mi casa y tenía muchísimas preguntas
en la cabeza claramente me olvidé de
comprar la mitad de las cosas de la
lista del supermercado esto también
había que decirlo tenía preguntas como
cómo podría existir esa conexión tan
fuerte como una persona desconocida o
cuáles eran las herramientas para poder
enfrentar estas batallas y ese dolor tan
grande que puede generar una experiencia
o una vivencia necesitaba entender
tantas cosas y encontrar tantas
respuestas pero ya sabes he dicho que
dice si caminas solo irás más rápido si
caminas acompañado
llegarás mucho más lejos
bueno en mi corazón si tenía muy claro
que en esta oportunidad quería llegar
lejos quería descubrir todas estas
respuestas a estas preguntas en compañía
quería descubrir estas respuestas en
comunidad esa misma tarde recuerdo estar
sentada en el comedor de mi casa
acumulamos en blanco y un bolígrafo y me
di a mi misma y si empiezo a compartir
en redes sociales las diferentes
batallas a las que nos enfrentamos las
mujeres situaciones cotidianas
situaciones fuertes rupturas ausencias
decisiones momentos vivencias saben de
esos pensamientos que te llegan a la
cabeza y dices por qué no y me pregunte
qué es lo peor que puede pasar aunque
una vez una gran amiga me dijo que
suplantará la pregunta qué es lo peor
que podía pasar por qué es lo mejor que
podía pasar
y así empecé compartiendo vídeos e
historias en 15 segundos en una cuenta
que tenía muy pocas seguidoras la
mayoría eran desconocidas y con las
herramientas que tenía en ese momento un
teléfono y la luz natural de la ventana
tras publicar algunos vídeos historias
empecé a recibir mensajes muy curiosos
como a mí me ha pasado eso me siento
identificada o estoy viviendo esta
situación y no sé cómo salir de ahí
recibía mensajes como gracias gabriela
me siento muchísimo mejor al contarte mi
historia y que me escucharás desde la
empatía y no desde el juicio y así fue
como empecé a preguntarme a mí mismo
pero que hice como una persona se puede
sentir mejor si solamente la escucha
como una persona puede sentirse mejor
sólo con saber que alguien está ahí para
escucharla muy curioso sumando día a día
historias experiencias vivencias llegué
a una conclusión y es que en comunidad
con apoyo se alivia ese peso en el que
traemos vamos a llamar la mochila y
vamos a llamar a esa mochila vida sin
darme cuenta empecé a construir un
espacio libre de crítica donde las
experiencias las vivencias las emociones
se fueron convirtiendo día a día
donde no existen filtros y cada mujer
dejaba que la vulnerabilidad fluyera sin
miedo al qué dirán dónde existen más
oídos que bocas de jueces sin título ya
que cuando vivimos situaciones que nos
rompen lo que necesitamos es que alguien
esté allí para escucharnos y no que a la
primera salga de su boca te lo dije o
hemos del famoso te lo dije
fui confirmando que cuando estamos
viviendo situaciones que nos generan
dolor
buscamos protección buscamos apoyo en
otra persona
dentro de este espacio libre de críticas
hay ciertas reglas o vamos a llamar las
normativas que nos unen como mujeres no
se aceptan groserías ni malas palabras
no hay insultos ni se puede juzgar ni
criticar la historia de otra persona la
escucha activa es la base de cualquier
inicio de conversación nosotras siempre
tenemos la mano extendida para cualquier
situación de emergencia en la que
estemos viviendo en este espacio la
protección la sensibilidad la
resiliencia la compañía la disposición
la empatía son nuestros pilares
fundamentales y ustedes se preguntarán
cuál es el beneficio principal de estar
y convivir en comunidad y el beneficio
principal es poder conectar y conectar
con personas que te entiendan conectar
con personas que hablen tu mismo idioma
o mejor dicho un idioma lleno de empatía
en comunidad solo se habla desde el
corazón
no tenemos vergüenza a conversar ni a
hablar sobre ningún tema ni ninguna
situación o vivencia de esas de esas
situaciones que nos duelen muchísimo
porque sabemos que estamos en una
verdadera fraternidad o hermandad donde
nos escuchamos nos apoyamos de una
manera incondicional
la comunidad te enseña a compartir sí a
compartir esa carga emocional que todos
traemos porque el caminar en la vida se
puede hacer más sencillo si esto lo
compartes cuando compartes tus tristezas
sus carencias tus debilidades tus
defectos ojos pero también tus logros
tus oportunidades
tus alegrías todo se puede vivir mucho
mejor vivir y compartir tus creencias
tus valores de vida es caminar siempre
acompañada y poder tener la oportunidad
de ver el mundo con otros ojos
el entendernos y comprendernos y ser
solidarias entre nosotras mismas es
parte de nuestro día a día en este
espacio virtual esta comunidad de
historias reales y de amigas virtuales
nos ha enseñado a establecer límites
límites que los vemos desde el amor
hacia nosotras mismas entendimos que esa
conexión que se genera con una persona
desconocida viene desde la comprensión y
de realmente en colocarte en los zapatos
de otra persona y sentir ese dolor esa
ausencia
esa situación fuerte que estás viviendo
la comunidad te enseña a vivir de una
forma distinta te invita a crecer de la
mano con otra mujer te recuerda el valor
que tienes y te permite realzar tu
dignidad con muchas más mujeres día a
día compartir en este grupo de amigas me
ha hecho confirmar que somos seres
sociales y como lo dijo maría gabriela
una amiga virtual parte de esta
comunidad
la comunidad nos forja nos edifica y nos
hace ver que todo lo que vivimos que
todas las etapas por las que vamos
pasando la mayoría de los seres humanos
las viven
mire así como buscamos fortalecer
nuestro sistema inmune también
necesitamos fortalecer nuestro sistema
emocional y ustedes se preguntarán cómo
puedo fortalecer el sistema emocional
recuerda que esta mochila a la que le
llamamos vida de la que hemos venido
hablando dentro de esta mochila también
tenemos armas como la valentía la
resiliencia la sensibilidad el amor el
cariño la reinvención la empatía el dar
sin recibir nada a cambio el afecto y
esas ganas enormes de realmente ayudar a
alguien cuando lo necesita
estas son las verdaderas armas lo que
pasa es que no me los enseñan
son las verdaderas armas que van a
liberar cualquier batalla que nos toca
vivir o experimentar
el conversar y el escuchar se convirtió
prácticamente en un método de liberación
absoluto
es entender que no se actúa desde la
maldad sino desde el dolor desde las
heridas desde ausencias desde las
carencias que traemos como ser humano la
palabra y condicional cobra sentido
cuando compartes día a día con personas
que están 100% a tu disposición y es que
al final la vida no tendría sentido si
no dejamos la mano extendida para quien
lo necesita y utilizamos la pregunta en
que te puedo ayudar
en estos casi siete años que tenemos
conviviendo en comunidad para mí ha sido
extraordinario he aprendido cosas que ni
la mejor escuela ni el mejor colegio me
han podido enseñar he elegido y
escuchado historias que ni el mejor
escritor de hollywood les puedo asegurar
ha escrito
y hasta es yo participe de los mejores
actos de magia a través de una
conversación o mejor dicho de
conversaciones que se han convertido en
un vínculo y un vínculo que es para toda
la vida
y es que las personas que conforman esta
hermandad son realmente mágicas son
personas que son capaces de cambiar y
mejorar mi día y el de las mujeres que
son parte de esto son capaces de ser el
motor de inspiración para muchísimas
mujeres a través de testimonios de
historias de sus experiencias sin duda
hoy puedo decirles que amigos virtuales
hemos construido un nexo inquebrantable
miren una vez una amiga virtual que es
parte de esta comunidad llamada marvel y
espinoza dijo algo así como para mí
compartir en comunidad es una conexión
mágica tenemos una hermandad que aún sin
conocernos estamos aquí a disposición
nos juzgamos sólo leemos escuchamos y
aconsejamos
ser parte de esta comunidad es mágico
ser parte de esta comunidad y es
maravilloso
y si hoy desde tu espacio empiezas a
construir una comunidad y si hoy
empiezan a utilizar la comprensión para
no buscar y si entendemos que nadie
tiene la verdad absoluta sino diferentes
puntos de vista y es válido y si hoy
desde tu espacio empiezas a generar un
cambio y empiezas a construir un espacio
libre de crítica yo te puedo asegurar a
ti que cambiará tu vida y cambiarás la
vida de las personas que tienes a tu
alrededor
puedes ser capaz de dejar una huella en
este mundo recuerda eres lo que haces
eres las veces que realmente comprendes
a la persona que tienes a tu lado
recuerda eres las veces que a pesar de
no tener tiempo de ir muy rápido te
detuviste a escuchar a la persona que lo
necesito
eres las veces que respetas los
diferentes puntos de vista y utilizas la
comprensión como base de vida eres las
veces que sumas en vez de restar o
juzgar
eres las veces que desde tu espacio
quieres construir algo distinto eres las
veces que abrazaste cuando no habían
palabras
yo siempre escucho a muchas personas que
dicen constantemente que quieren ayudar
que quieren empezar a aportar algo en el
mundo pero al final eso se queda y nadie
toma acción no hacen nada llegó el
momento llegó el momento de unirnos como
seres humanos llegó el momento de dejar
la apatía hacia los demás llegó el
momento de poner en práctica esas
palabras yo quiero ayudar y hacerlo
realidad miren les cuento una anécdota
en una mis películas favoritas que se
llama comer esa llama que está basada en
el libro de elizabeth gilbert se
menciona un chiste italiano muy bueno
que dice algo así un pobre que va a la
iglesia todos los días a rezar frente a
un santo le dice por favor por favor por
favor que me gane la lotería y al final
el santo ya desesperado cobra vida baja
la mirada y le dice por favor por favor
por favor compra un ticket de la lotería
si de verdad es que vamos a empezar a
mejorar el mundo debemos poner de
nuestra parte y debemos empezar a hacer
cosas diferentes
te pido a ti que desde hoy empieces a
construir comunidad con el objetivo
principal de ayudar y apoyar de una
manera incondicional hoy te pido que
desde tu espacio logremos que la
sensibilidad no se vaya a extinguir y
que los abrazos se multipliquen que su
planteamos la crítica por una mano en el
hombro y que la solidaridad el respeto y
la comprensión
siempre se hagan presente día a día
entre los seres humanos para poder
construir comunidades reales desde la
empatía y desde el corazón muchísimas
gracias